welcome to the stream Wow Wow
this could be this could be the biggest
stream since who knows when given what's
going on and the news that has broken
even since we finished today's show
already just major major news relating
to Donald Trump and before we even get
into the news if you want to find an
indicator that tells us things are
really getting bad for Trump PPP has
been doing a poll for about three months
asking Americans do you want to impeach
Donald Trump do you support impeaching
Donald Trump now it doesn't matter that
most people don't understand that
impeachment isn't actually the removal
of the president but the beginning of
proceedings to figure out whether the
president will be found guilty or not of
some wrongdoing doesn't matter that PPP
is a left-leaning polling firm because
they've been doing this poll for a while
and typically you had a split between
people who favored supported and opposed
impeaching Donald Trump there is now a
plurality of Americans 48% of Americans
according to this poll now support the
impeachment of Donald Trump compared to
only 41% who oppose the impeachment of
Donald Trump and imagine if more people
knew that impeachment doesn't mean
remove the president it just means start
the process an impeachment is sort of
like an indictment of sorts and a lot of
people believe that in saying I want to
impeach means I want to remove Trump
today that's not even what impeachment
means of course Bill Clinton was
impeached but as you remember he was not
removed from office and the numbers just
stunning and not good not good for
Donald Trump and we're going to go
through all the breaking news so to
catch you up number one over the last 24
hours we found out that Donald Trump the
day after firing James Comey presumably
biological
because he wanted to interfere with the
investigation by the FBI into the Trump
Russia scandal the day after that firing
Donald Trump invites to the White House
Sergey Lavrov and Sergey cos lyac two
Russian diplomats the latter of whom
kiss lyac is the Russian ambassador at
the center of so many of these meetings
that uh Trump associates lied about
meetings with Jeff Sessions meetings
with Michael Flynn meetings with Jared
Kushner that guy gets invited to the
Oval Office and not only are they
invited to the Oval Office American
media is not allowed to cover it Russian
media is allowed to cover that visit and
the only pictures from that visit are
Russian media pictures okay we knew all
that up until before yesterday yesterday
we learned based on a Washington Post
report which Donald Trump I want to be
super clear about this Donald Trump has
not denied leaking secret information to
the Russians
he has defended doing it okay he has
tried to justify doing it we learned as
you probably have heard by now that
indeed Donald Trump leaked I don't know
if leaked is even the right word spilled
the beans on highly classified
information that we my immediate
suspicion when we heard that it was
information the u.s. u.s. got from a
middle-eastern now I was that it was
Israel it now appears that indeed it was
Israel that gave Donald Trump this
information which he subsequently leaked
to his Russian visitors stunning I mean
just absolutely and utterly stunning
that's where we were as of three hours
ago when we finished today's program and
you can already start to see some of
those clips pop up on our YouTube
channel but a lot has broken since then
this could be this week might be the
most news filled week with regard to
Trump Russia with regard to Trump and
competency with regard to Trump
delusions of grandeur but before we get
to that a few just housekeeping things
if this is your first David Pakman show
YouTube livestream number one yes we're
really live I'm really doing this right
now I'm
do you now assuming at 6:33 p.m. Eastern
Time on May 16 2017 if it's some other
time you may be watching a replay number
two super chat is on ok the chat moves
really quickly during the streams so if
you want to get a question or comment in
that I will read and if there's a
question in there answer feel free to
use super chat that's the dollar sign at
the bottom of the chat window number
three any new members or patrons who
subscribe or pledge during the
livestream will get a live shout out and
thank you from me I will sing your
praises to everybody who is watching
live with us you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show for patreon that is what
keeps us independent and on-air
a number for obvious trolling and hate
will get you banned what's amaze in one
of our moderators already blocked or
time someone out obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned subtle trolling
probably won't if it's subtle enough ok
so let's get into some of the breaking
news and then after we will get into
super chats and so much else of what's
going on it's going to be a wacky 24
hours that's for sure ok what have we
learned
above and beyond what we knew as of this
afternoon which is Trump allegedly
leaked this information HR McMaster said
no he didn't then Trump goes on Twitter
12 hours later and explains why he did
so not exactly congruent messaging from
Trump and his team number one
we now have a New York Times article
alleging that in the meeting this
infamous meeting do we have tapes of
this meeting or do we not have tapes of
this meeting I don't know we will maybe
find out someday but in that meeting
Donald Trump and I I'm I'm hesitating
because this it's so insane that this is
what's going on but every indication is
that it's true James Comey wrote a memo
a fired FBI director after that meeting
with Trump saying that Donald Trump
asked him to end the investigation in
Michael Flynn which is directly
connected to Trump Russia disgraced
national security advisor Michael Flynn
this is being reported right now by the
New York Times if this is true and so
far let's be quite frank this is it's
logically fallacious to assume that
because a past assertion was true a new
assertion is true but as a general
concept the New York Times has not been
wrong in their reporting on Trump Russia
much and we now have an article by
Michael Schmidt just came out Comey memo
says Trump asked him to end
flin investigation President Trump asked
the FBI director James Comey to shut
down the federal investigation into
Trump's former national security adviser
Michael Flynn in an oval office meeting
in February according to a memo the
James Comey wrote shortly after the
meeting apparently according to the New
York Times article James Comey was so
distraught by what he had been asked to
do by the President of the United States
that he shared it with others and said
this is what I've been asked to do this
represents the worst of crony
business-as-usual establishment swamp
filling politics in the United States
this is someone who by asking for the
FBI director to end an investigation by
making that request Donald Trump is
saying I don't give two shits about the
Independence of the judiciary I don't
care about separation of powers I am the
president and you will do as I say which
is not something that is in line with
American values and the American system
of government there's really no way to
say it any other way
this is a fundamental attack an attack
on the sort of foundation the legal
foundation the administrative foundation
that the country is built on and there
will no doubt my prediction is over the
next 24 hours we will get denials that
this is something that Trump asked James
Comey to do and it will probably be
replaced by some other scandal because
that's the way things have been going
okay so that is major Comey being asked
by the president allegedly to stop an
investigation shouldn't law enforcement
decide when an investigation should
start and when an investigation should
stop isn't that something that only the
the individual agency doing the
investigating could really decide when
is appropriate why would how would a
president know when it makes sense to
start or stop an investigation and if
you imagine the president going to the
FBI and saying hey can you stop that
investigation into a plot to bomb an
American city we would all say wait a
second it's it's the FBI that informs
the president when it's time to stop the
investigation not the president that
demands of the FBI so this is an
absolute and utter abortion number two
that has leaked or orbit that we've
learned since we finished our broadcast
program earlier today Donald Trump
according to a new report didn't know
where the intelligence came from when he
leaked it to those Russian officials in
the Oval Office the day after firing
James Comey this is now yet another part
of the building scandal the independent
is reporting that the president wasn't
briefed on the sources and methods
relevant to that Isis related
information that he spilled the beans on
to Sergey Lavrov and Sergey kis lack the
intelligence is said to have come from
an American ally in the Middle East my
assumption was that Ally was Israel
there are now some anecdotal reports
saying yes it was Israel and Donald
Trump apparently had no idea what it was
that he was even telling these
individuals and I don't know if that
makes it better or worse it seems to me
to make it even worse shouldn't the
president have the buck stops with the
president
is what I'm saying shouldn't the
president have some sense of what it is
that he is talking to not allies about
adversarial foreign national diplomats
about before he says hey here's some
great Intel that I've got stunning
absolutely stunning we now have that
revelation as well there are a growing
list of similarities between Donald
Trump and Richard Nixon I already talked
earlier I guess it was last late last
week or early this week about the
similarity lately was late last week
about similarities between the firing of
James Comey and what is known as the
Saturday night Mac massacre with
relation to Watergate and the Nixon
administration Richard Nixon trying to
avert disaster when it came to Watergate
by trying to fire the then Attorney
General relates to this incident now
known as the Saturday Saturday night
Saturday night massacre not Saturday
Night Live and Donald Trump firing James
Comey by all indications to try to
interrupt the investigation into Trump
Russia potentially taping conversations
we know that audio recordings were a big
thing in Watergate we now have every
reason to believe that Donald Trump that
there are recordings of what's going on
in the Oval Office not just the phone
system we know the phone system has a
switch which you can turn on or off to
record any conversation that president
Trump's phone is engaged in but there
was in The Washington Post report
yesterday that broke the story about
Trump leaking secret information to
Russia it mentioned that there was an
effort being made to modify the full
transcript to no longer include those
leaks if there is a transcript it
follows that there is a recording and
again recording in Watergate recording
by Donald Trump symptoms of extreme
paranoia Watergate Richard Nixon no
shortage of those Donald Trump 2017 no
shortage of symptoms of unusually
extreme paranoia and number four this
concept that what the president does
just isn't illegal Richard Nixon
for that phrase that assertion and now
Donald Trump choosing by confirming by
defending why he leaked this information
to Russia he's basically saying if the
president does it it's not illegal he is
right in the sense that the president
can choose to declassify anything by
talking about it that's a separate
question from whether it's morally right
from whether it puts the u.s. at
national security risk whether it
damages relationships with important
allies whether it gives information to
those we are trying to capture in this
particular case a plot related to ISIL
Isis so this is absolute and total
madness that we are dealing with a few
other things Eric eris Erickson who's a
conservative has said that the situation
around Trump leaking secrets is worse
than reported that's interesting I think
we're going to find out more about that
eventually and I want to remind you and
I'll probably talk about this on
tomorrow's program that Donald Trump
once demanded Edward Snowden's execution
forgiving what he called serious
information to Russia did Donald Trump
give serious information to Russia by
leaking information that we were given
presumably by Israeli intelligence and
told don't spread this around don't even
spread this around to allies and then in
the Oval Office Trump goes and he spills
it to a non particularly friendly nation
and to Sergey kis lyac an alleged and
suspected Russian spy recruiter Russian
spy recruiter absolutely crazy Trump
bashing Hillary Clinton over her
handling of classified information so
there is a this is scandal at the
absolute highest level and it is
stunning what is going on that that's
the those are the new pieces of
information that we've learned just in
the last few hours
what will we know tomorrow let's go to a
few super chats that we have here Fabian
sharer says with a - Swiss franc super
chat great update cheers never knew
about super chat will thing
very much now you know about it Isaiah
Rho sent a five-dollar super chat saying
fake news from Alex Jones yes Alex Jones
uh yeah no comment no further comment on
that super chat is on feel free to use
it okay a couple other things to go
through number one we do have now a
patreon page okay we are suffering at
the hands of what is called the YouTube
advertiser boycott colloquially known as
ad pocalypse we have lost at this point
it's two-thirds of our YouTube revenue
overnight gone we need to replace that
revenue and in fact I hate to let let me
let me even pause what I'm doing I
wasn't going to do this right now but
it's just been confirmed that one of our
videos today has lost monetization and
I've just got to explain to you the
level of [ __ ] that we're dealing
with we did a story today okay the video
clip is live on our YouTube channel it
went live at 4:30 p.m. Eastern about two
hours ago it is called breaking Trump
revealed highly classified intelligence
to Russians in the Oval Office video
goes live at four thirty four thirty one
video is d monetized ads no longer
running video no longer making money why
we took special care in that video not
to make anything on any descriptions of
violence not to show any violence or
gore there's no profanity in this video
it is 100% FCC safe and it has been
demonetised and I don't know why I've
reached out to YouTube I've asked for an
explanation I've been told that they are
going to look into it and maybe I would
hear something by tomorrow
sadly the first 24 hours are sort of the
most important hours for a breaking news
video the video already has about 15,000
views according to the live count the
the public count is only at four
thousand that takes a little while to
update and we are making no money on
that video and this is part of the
YouTube D monetization crisis that we
are dealing with and we've got to make
up this revenue
we've done a couple things number one we
do have a patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
[Music]
when we get to 2,000 patrons I've agreed
to do an entire episode of the David
Pakman show from our studio with my hair
what I call uncontrolled this is what
happens to my hair when I don't control
it with product and maybe against my
better judgment I've agreed to do an
entire broadcast episode of the show
from our studio with this hair once we
get to 2,000 patrons we're now just over
1,500 you can pledge as little as $1
don't think that if you can only pledge
$1 it's not worth pledging it is because
if everybody pledged $1 we would much
more than make up for the lost revenue
we also of course are we have membership
available membership is the number one
funding source for the David Pakman show
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership and after selecting
your membership and hitting the sign-up
button you'll be presented with a coupon
code field and in that coupon code field
if you would like a 40% discount off of
membership you can type in I voted 17
and you know what obviously it would be
better if if you can afford the normal
price pay the normal price but we want
people involved at any level use the
coupon code if you want
I voted 17 and we will get to a lot of
people have already been signing up and
pledging just while I've been talking
here and we'll do some thank yous a
little bit later on in the live stream
let's get to some other super chats DW
Washburn has sent a super chat for $20
saying David do you think Trump will
ever be impeached you know if I had to
handicap it right now I think that there
is a good chance that Trump does get
impeached but again impeachment does not
mean a removal from the White House
impeachment means that there are
proceedings the president is being
accused of some wrongdoing and then we
will have to go through that process so
I think it's certainly possible that
there will be an impeachment
will it lead to a removal from the White
House that's a different question
Farrell kimchi has sent a five-dollar
super chat asking would you rather
people support support via patreon or
membership which benefits you the most
listen what benefits us the most is the
biggest number of dollars possible if
you've only got a dollar or two per
month to contribute membership even with
the 40% discount is 3.60 cents a month
so if you've only got $1 to do the
patreon thing if you want something
simple and you don't want to deal with
how do I log in how do I get the members
stream of the show the commercial free
video whatever I just do the patreon
thing patreon.com slash david pakman
show if you're interested in the member
benefits and you want to do a little
more you know 360 a month or six bucks a
month or whatever by all means do the
membership thing they're both great ok
they both go directly to us - some some
payment processing fees I've had some
concerns initially that patreon
processing fees were quite high they've
been reduced significantly so it's very
close to membership do what you can do
what you what you're more comfortable
with Julian carrion sent a $5 super chat
with no question or comment thank you
very much tre BD has sent a twenty
dollar super chat here's a few bucks to
help with ad pocalypse have you kept up
with Claude Taylor Louise mensch John
Schindler etc on Twitter they seem to be
at the vanguard of these big stories
I've kept up a lot with Claude Taylor
I've kept up a little with Louise mensch
and I've not kept up with John Schindler
to be honest I haven't heard of John
Schindler let me make a note to check
out John Schindler after the livestream
yeah and what's Claude Taylor I haven't
checked out Claude Taylor's checked out
Claude Taylor's tweets today breaking
news Israel provided the intelligence we
assume that folks are asking for an
update here is what I know the IDI VA
has one of the heaviest dockets in the
US with an average of 11 I don't know
what I think this relates to sealed
indictments that Claude Taylor has been
talking about for a while in any case
yes a lot a lot of good people to follow
their game fire 74 has sent a 16 dollar
and forty four cent super chat very
specific amount thank you I agree that
the last seven days have been pure
madness is the media hurting its
credibility by being so sensationalized
or outraged also how are the Trump is
not disillusioned cult of personality
last part first yeah
trumpets have Trump mister what's called
in poker
they are pot committed they've invested
so much that at this point it makes
sense for them to stick it out and just
see what happens and not bail on Trump
although his approval rating is back
down to 38 percent which is close to his
record low is the media hurting its
credibility by being sensationalized or
outraged I don't think so I you know the
reality is that if anything overall I
believe that what's going on with Donald
Trump is being under sensationalized in
the sense that there are so many
scandals that they're blending and we're
losing track Ivanka Trump getting a
security clearance and an office at the
White House
despite anti-nepotism laws which are
circumvented by not giving her an
official position in a normal
administration that would be a 3-week
scandal it was six hours or twelve hours
because it's scandal after scandal so if
anything I believe that that it is being
under sensationalized if you can believe
it and certainly by the way if you go on
Fox News everything's fine I mean
there's just nothing's going on it's
just hey you know the president is an
economic conservative and you know
patriotism and all that stuff it's like
nothing is going on other than some
liberals who are doing some wacky and
weird stuff Nicolas sera via has sent a
ten Swedish kronor super chat no
question or comment thank you very much
I appreciate that okay let's do some
thank-yous because they've been coming
in number one new patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have Glenny
Fitzgerald who has pledged two dollars a
month richard robertson has pledged $10
a month
sarah tan has pledged two dollars a
month thank you very very much I really
do appreciate that and we've got you
know we've got an uphill battle here
let's put it that way
membership new members while we've been
chatting here John McClane not John
McCain but John McClane has signed up
with the coupon code I voted 17 at david
pakman.com slash membership Molly
McDonald has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code
Fernando Espinoza has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership francis
Berwyn has signed up without using the
coupon code thanks Francis at david
pakman.com slash membership and lastly
Valerie Applebaum
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership so big thank you we are
dealing still with YouTube ad pocalypse
we've lost about two thirds of our
YouTube revenue and as I mentioned even
just basic uncontroversial videos like
our video about Trump leaking
information in the Oval Office certainly
relates the political controversy but no
violence or gore or discussions of
bombings or war or anything like that
certainly no profanity completely work
safe and disappointing very very
disappointing what's going on right now
5euro super chat has come in from AK
well thanks for keeping us informed
keeping us in europe informed about the
totally crazy [ __ ] going on at your side
of the pond my pleasure I don't know if
pleasure is the right word but it
certainly seems like the right thing to
be doing Hobbiton has sent a 20 british
pound super chat people think that you
can throw a political molotov by voting
right to spite the left they dislike but
between Trump and brexit it seems like
they hurt those who throw more the
politicians they aim at hurt those who
throw more of the politicians they aim
what do you think you know I'm not
totally sure I hunted percent understand
the question but I that voting right to
spite the left you don't like is a big
mistake
I've been very clear about this in the
primary in the United States the
Democrat I'm not a Democrat or a
Republican in the state of Massachusetts
I can choose to vote in either primary I
voted in the Democratic primary at that
time I believe that the best choice was
Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders ultimately
did not win the Democratic nomination on
election day the options were Gary
Johnson Jill Stein Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton and I believed and I
know I just some of my viewers disagree
with me on this I believe that from
those options the most logical choice
overall the the best choice based on
experience and ever in baton balance was
Hillary Clinton and I voted for Hillary
Clinton I wanted to try to spite the
left could have said I'll vote Trump or
Gary Johnson or whatever wouldn't have
made a difference here in Massachusetts
but no I don't I don't agree with that
sentiment Hobbiton sandy Whelan has sent
a 25 Canadian dollar super chat
Canadians care and support you thank you
very much sandy appreciate that andrew
jones has sent a $2 and 66 cent super
chat go show Curt Schilling's some love
on Twitter y'all oh god what is Curt
Schilling saying on Twitter now Curt
Schilling is the former Boston Red Sox
pitcher who is a right wing nut I mean I
don't know how else to say it and I
guess he might be running for Senate
here in Massachusetts which would be
pretty scary let's see he's tweeting
about he tweeted two hours ago oh this
is so funny he tweeted two hours ago
he retweeted Newt Gingrich saying that
he's never seen such deliberate
dishonesty from The Washington Post in
New York Times you know they were right
about the Trump leaking secrets to
Russia thing Trump admitted it I got so
many messages from people after the
initial article went live from the
Washington Post of
Trump Russia scandal and people saying
David it son confirmed this person
denies that person denies then you know
Washington Post stands by it Washington
Post has been pretty good on this this
morning Donald Trump goes on Twitter and
explains why he leaked the information
to the Russian so I don't know where
Schilling is coming up with that but
pretty frustrating lady fair has sent a
$10 super chat no question or comment
thank you very very much
and Sigurd gel gel of i don't know how
to pronounce that has sent a fifty
norwegian kroner super chat saying keep
up the good work Dave here's a little
something to help you through the
[ __ ]
love from Norway our Constitution day
now by the way may 17th yes it is after
midnight in Norway and it is
Constitution day there in in Norway so
congratulations to the Norwegians I
recently flew on a Norwegian airline and
it was a great experience what that has
to do with your Constitution probably
nothing but it was a good experience
Courtney Haynes has sent a five-dollar
super check what do you say to people
liberal and conservative who repeat that
there is no evidence of Russian
collusion isn't this a disingenuous
argument that they're making yes there
is and you know when you talk about
there's no evidence what evidence do you
have personally that we went to the moon
right I mean to pick another conspiracy
theory but we can make assessments based
on the systems we have and the
interrelations that we have between
different systems and we can determine
whether it's likely that something is
true or not and at this point you know
people say we have only a little smoke
we don't have fire Trump firing Comey is
fire all of these things that we've seen
are the fire it's gone beyond smoke and
I think that there's very little to that
assertion and it's becoming more and
more clear really just about every day
Courtney
Klaus m54 has sent a 2 euro super chat
with no question or comment thank you
very much I I do appreciate that we are
going to be talking tomorrow on the
program and I
but at the beginning of the livestream I
talked about this a little bit a
plurality of Americans now support the
impeachment of Donald Trump 48 to 47
Americans support over oppose the
impeachment of Donald Trump this is the
highest number that this PPP poll has
seen since they started doing that
question in the poll three months ago
and as I mentioned earlier in the super
chin the live stream most people don't
even understand many people don't even
understand that impeachment doesn't mean
the immediate removal of a president if
more people understood that impeachment
just means we believe the president has
done something wrong and we are going to
impeach you were just starting the
process that's just the beginning not
the end and I think if more people knew
that you would have way more than 48
percent saying impeachment yeah that
does make sense right now we're going to
be talking about that tomorrow we also
have hatred mail on tomorrow's program
hey treat male sort of relates here to
not directly but it does sort of relate
to many of the issues we've been talking
about today and so much breaking news
and you know what it's almost pointless
for me to even tell you about what's on
tomorrow's show because who knows what
will happen at 350 2:00 a.m. this
morning on Twitter on Donald Trump's
Twitter and it could upend what we're
planning on doing tomorrow
game fire 74 has sent a $3 and ninety
one cent super jet can you do updates on
the special elections I should do that
I'm going to try to do that and
yeah okay every once in a while I like
to just take a quick scroll through all
the comments a lot of people getting
themselves banned in the comments which
is never surprising I have fully
deputized our moderators they know
exactly what the standards are that we
are applying obvious trolling and hate
obvious trolling and hate will get you
banned someone just talking about a lot
of just very very lame like what someone
just posted for example that they want
to perform fellatio on a horse I mean
you're just block hears there's no
warning I've just blocked you don't
worry about it
RDR and and the other mods that are here
it's just nonsense it to distraction
we're not we're not going to allow it
okay eke it cat JJ has sent a $2.00
super Chad we need to know what's going
on so we can step up well I don't know
with what you know I don't know you need
to know what's going on with what so you
can step up but I'm doing my best to
keep you informed both about what's
going on with the David Pakman show and
what's going on
with news and politics let's get to a
few more thank yous here okay new
members coming in fast and furious here
continued new members
Joseph sharp has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Jennifer
Kish pas has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership leslie
yellow has signed up on our website
Tyler Youngblood Thank You Tyler for
signing up for a new membership on our
website John Taylor is a brand new
member as is ferial vanden Heuvel thank
you thank you for your support really
really appreciate it also new patrons
making pledges small and large at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
Coleen Harrison has made a $2.00 per
month pledge I really really appreciate
that and max Ryan has also made a $2
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show really important we are at a 66%
deficit of YouTube ad revenue because of
what is known as YouTube ad pocalypse I
don't want this to affect the show in
any way which is why we're doing
everything we can to replace as much of
that income as possible using two means
membership as well as patreon so thank
you thank you very much let's get to a
few more Super chats here okay
Coco's dad has sent a twenty Canadian
dollar super chat with no question or
comment appreciate it thank you very
much mister Toit's au has sent a to
British pound super chat do you think
Trump is 100% loyal to the United States
or a faker I don't know if it's a
question of being a faker Trump is loyal
to the u.s. to the extent that it serves
his interests and those are political
interests business interests but more
importantly his sort of interests
related to his personal ego to that
extent he will be loyal but that's about
as far as it goes and I think his long
history of business dealings tells us a
lot about that Pat Everhart has sent a
20 I'm sorry a 10 US dollar super chat
with no question or comment thank you
very much Titan bait Titan bait has sent
a $5 super chat what do you think of the
two-term cap on US presidencies do you
think it would be more democratic to
have no limit like when like with
Franklin Delano Roosevelt or is he an
outlier I think that a two-term limit on
on president is okay you could make a
case for one six-year term as some
countries have where we really need term
limits is with members of the House and
Senate and I know that there is an
argument that sometimes people will make
saying listen David you are going to
term limit a lot of people you were
going to term limit a lot of good people
out of office and we need good people I
sort of think that that risk is far
outweighed by the fact that if we had
term limits in the House and Senate
number one we would we would ideally get
a bigger diversity of voices you could
still have mostly rich lawyers being
elected but it's at least possible you
might have more
and you might also eliminate some of the
impetus to be corrupt if you are not
angling for your next election you do
have some more freedom although it's a
fair argument to say well but you're
still going to try to not screw over
whoever is going to try to replace you
from your party so I think there's there
there are arguments to be made either
way but I believe that House and Senate
we should definitely be looking at term
limits repentant gamer has sent a 10
dollar super chat I was wondering if you
saw the news article in The New York
Times and Daily Beast that Emmanuel
macron s campaign managed to outsmart
Russian hackers by giving them fake
information on purpose I did see the
article the article and in fact I have
it bookmarked the article is called it's
from May 9th called hackers came but the
French were prepared in the New York
Times very good article if I don't get
to talk about that on the regular show
by Friday I will probably talk about
that on the bonus show because it's a
very very interesting story and
everybody should check it out very
interesting cool drone Jones has sent a
2.22 sent super chat do you think we'll
get past political tribalism um
the yes-or-no answer to that question I
think is less relevant then can we
empower people through a better
epistemology in terms of how we know
what we know how we gather information
and sort of form our opinions I think
that there's a lot more to be gained
there than just the the sort of you know
yes/no question of ending tribalism game
fire 586 has said have you already
talked about the breaking news of the
Comey memos on this livestream Comey was
asked to drop the Mike Flynn thing yes
game fire very good question at the
beginning of the stream you can go back
to it and check it out after we I did
talk about that yes Michael Flynn has uh
James Comey fired FBI director James
Comey wrote a memo saying
when I met with Trump in February he
told me stop investigating Michael Flynn
and this is this is a breach of Trump is
saying I [ __ ] on separation of powers
and I don't give a flying you-know-what
about the independence of the judiciary
and it is an absolute and utter
atrocious abortion that Donald Trump did
that and we're going to believe me we're
going to dig into that in detail on
tomorrow's show Coco's dad sent a twenty
Canadian dollar super chat thank you
very much appreciate that ml Romero sent
a $5 super chat saying just helping
support the show thank you so much and
Coco's dad's sending I believe a third
twenty Canadian dollar super chat
Trump's campaign promise to bring back
waterboarding may have been prophetic
he's blindly drowning himself while
simultaneously giving the world's
intelligence services control over the
tap very poetic
Coco's dad very very poetic I I think
that there's there's a lot to what
you're saying they're very very
interesting okay before I we have I'm
humbled at the number of new members
that are signing up during this live
stream and helping us fight back against
YouTube ad pocalypse let me say a big
thank you to Wayne Anthony Wayne Anthony
went to david pakman.com slash
membership put in the coupon code
I voted 17 got 40% off and is now a
member getting access to among other
things the daily members only bonus show
very very popular member benefit Michael
Kennedy has signed up with the 40%
discount at david pakman.com slash
membership kimberly Mooney has signed up
with the discount sharon Costello has
signed up with the discount Robert
Sigmund has signed up with a 40%
discount Claire yang has signed up with
a 40% discount Thank You Steven Ernst
key as well as Joe Stephan Stephan and
Joe thank you guys for signing up Eugene
has signed up as has Robin van Meter
Jacob Saunders and actually s : thank
you thank you we are we're doing what we
can right in April we had a record
number of new members record number of
new members about a thousand new members
at david pakman.com slash membership and
we also brought in about 1500 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we've had several hundred new members so
far in May although it has slowed down
because understandably the the YouTube
ad pocalypse situation has sort of
become old news in a sense
and although the urgency for us hasn't
changed people can get fatigued then I
get that and we're still stuck right
around 1,500 patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show so we're trying
to get to 2,000 okay so you can if you
can throw in a dollar or two there it is
much appreciated we've got more super
chats coming in Ashley D Rolfe has sent
a dollar super chat no question or
comment thanks very much Ashley
Athena Harding has sent a $10 super chat
I really appreciate these live streams
and how you interact directly with your
audience well thank you Athena really
really appreciate that and I like doing
the live streams and we'll keep them
going there are there we do an hour show
a day and then we do an extra 15 minutes
for our paid subscribers so you're not
going to fit the day's news in 275
minutes and it's nice to be able to just
kind of hang and answer questions from
the audience what's on people's minds
and it's great that we've got a
fantastic team of moderators that are
not allowing insane trolling to take
hold some of these moderators we have
overlapped with on our reddit discussion
forum and if you're not part of that
we're approaching 3,500 of our viewers
and listeners at david pakman.com slash
reddit there are really good discussions
political discussions that are happening
on our reddit and in fact our audit now
we now that we have close to 3,500
people that visit our reddit that's
enough people where often now when news
breaks I'm finding out about it because
one of you posted an article or a link
or a text post or whatever at our reddit
discussion forum so please participate
there I'm on there producer Pat is there
and it's great it's a great place to
just exchange ideas there are also some
conservatives there and by and large
they have been they've been keeping it
pretty clean I have to tell you they've
been doing they've been doing a very
very good job other stories and looking
at for later this week I did up as I
mentioned earlier I am looking at the
story of how the Emmanuel macron
campaign sort of outsmarted Russian
hackers in a sense when it came to those
email hacks I also want to talk about
and net neutrality as if you probably
know if you've been watching the program
for any length of time that I've been
talking about net neutrality for a very
very long time and it appears as though
a bunch of fake anti net neutrality
comments were sent to the FCC using
names and addresses of people without
their consent in other words not people
that are actually against net neutrality
they their names were used by someone to
send anti net neutrality comments to the
FCC and that is a that's pretty damn bad
and I'd like to talk about that story
we're also going to talk on oh okay let
me let me mention this because I saw a
couple people send a comment about it so
in the tweet that went out today teasing
today's bonus show there was something
in there about soda at a cardiologist
and what's that about I was at the
doctor yesterday which is why I was
broadcasting remotely yesterday it was
that a cardiology follow-up and many of
you already know the backstory of that I
won't dig into it now and I told a story
that a lot of people are already
emailing me about related to available
food and drink at my cardiologist office
and I encourage you if you sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership that'll give you instant
access to the bonus show check out
today's bonus show and you'll get that
that entire story and on that note we
have a number of new members here that
have signed up even just
in the last few minutes Leslie BN as
well as Dan Lennon who else here let me
see if I can scroll Bailey shervin and
Sean McQuarrie have all signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership and I
really really appreciate that I'm
actually going to get to work on
preparing for tomorrow's program not
short hours at the David Pakman show I
appreciate everybody who joined me
appreciate everybody who signed up and
by all means keep the patreon pledges
and new memberships coming and will
hopefully make up for what's going on
with YouTube ad pocalypse